ce robot est allé sur Mars forcément ça
intrigue le jeune public venu à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'occasion
de la fête nationale de la science la
rencontre entre le rover Curiosity et
les enfants à l'occasion pour les
scientifiques d'attirer de futurs
adeptes on arrive toujours à maîtriser
leur faire passer le message
leur dire que le compris fasse plus tard
dans les études ils pourront toujours
peut-être travailler pour le spatial
cette journée fut l'occasion pour les
chercheurs d'expliquer aux jeunes
publics leur métier et leurs projets
ainsi que leurs habitudes de travail au
quotidien
il y a de la vapeur d'eau qui va sortir
et comme on est dans des pièces dans des
pièces où
on essaye d'avoir justement le minimum
d'eau dans l'air pour pas que ça se
dépose sur sur ce qu'on est en train de
construire entre les ondes l'atmosphère
et autres capteurs les visiteurs d'un
jour en ont pris plein les yeux et les
oreilles alors bilan de la journée
qu'est-ce que le rover Curiosity c'est
un robot américain qui qui a été envoyé
sur Mars et qui qui est capable de
il est capable de d'analyser des roches
de
et aussi il est il a un mini laboratoire
dans son dans son corps j'ai aussi
appris comment on fait pour la météo
et pour tester les appareils avant de
les envoyer sur sur dans l'espace bref
de quoi tirer des plans sur la comète